How to make 1
internship in a European Union institution?
So today I'm going to show you where to apply.
So first of all,
we have this site called U E Career.
So it's really 1 site
that allows you to have access to all
careers and all job offers,
of internship.
So here for example,
I made 1
simulation with the Court of Justice of the Union
European.
So
to show you a little bit how it looks,
here,
we have 1 offer of internship in interpretation
to the Court of Justice of the European Union,
we have the location,
we have 1 small detail
of what they are looking for as a profile
and the duration.
So there,
as you can see,
is 10 to 12 weeks
here. For example,
for this offer,
he is looking for 5 months
1 person who is
holder of a law or science-po.
So feel free to check it out.
If you look closely,
you will also have offers from
internship at the Court of Auditors,
to the European Committee of the Regions.
So don't hesitate to check them out.
There if you go down,
you go to job and internship,
you have access to the position to be filled.
You can choose the institution,
the agency,
the domain. Here,
for example,
we have the agency berec
who is recruiting.
So now we have the mail,
so do not hesitate to make spontaneous applications.
We also have 1 phone number and 1 address.
Do not hesitate to go there if you.
You are close.
Do not hesitate to send letters too,
call them. Frankly,
you have to do everything.
If you are motivated,
don't hesitate to show them.
There are also
1 another site called the whole of Europe,
it's 1 site that also puts,
uh,
online internship offers,
of employment.
Here for example,
you have all the institutions that can
Recruit trainees,
the branches as well.
Here for example,
we have the blue book stage
which is proposed by the European Commission.
It is looking for licensees.
So frankly,
it's only bac plus 3.
Do not hesitate to apply.
So now it's 5 months of internship,
It can be very formative.
And on top of that,
it can be complicated.
Here we also have the boursouman intensive training courses
in the European Parliament.
So frankly,
it's 1 very very good
experience that you can bring to your CVs.